the video coming out on saturday this
week is going to be a follow-up on ezra
miller dealing with new allegations now
i'll get into all of this on saturday
but one thing i will not be doing in
that video is misgendering them because
i have seen that happening a lot
sometimes out of ignorance but i have
seen a disturbing number of people even
from within the lgbtqia plus community
making a decision to misgender them and
arguing that it's something we should do
and look i get wanting to put as much
distance as possible between us and them
especially if these allegations turn out
to be true but
opening the door and saying that there
are certain circumstances under which it
is acceptable to disregard someone's
identity that by all evidence they hold
sincerely the instant we do that to them
that says it's okay for other people to
deny our identities and pronouns for
their own reasons and i will not take
part of that i will deal with the actual
accusations but i will not be
misgendering them please don't do it
either